if you just want a crash course on
regression analysis then
you've come to the right place my name is
mathias and we'll go through the
basics of the most perfect analysis together we'll
start with the question what is
a regression analysis anyway and then
we'll look at simple and
multiple linear regression
discuss how to interpret the results
what the prerequisites
are and how to form the variables
then we come to the
logistical recession and the best
thing is i show you the topics discussed again and again in between you can
easily
calculate online with data and with
that i would say  let's start right away
what is a regression analysis a
regression analysis enables you
to conclude or predict another variant based on one or more variables
let's say you want to
find out what could have an influence on
a person's salary for this
For example, you take the highest level of
education, the
weekly hours worked, and
a person's age.
You could now examine whether these
three variables have an
impact on a person's salary. If the a
If they have an impact, then
you can predict a person's salary
by using  you want the
highest level of education the
weekly hours worked and the age of
a person indicates the variable
this closes so you
want to see before is called the dependent
variable or criterion the
variables you use to predict mr imst
are called independent variables or
projectors with recession analysis
can now  two goals are pursued you
can measure the influence of one or
more variables on another
variable or predict a variable
based on other variables
so that you can get a
feel for this we'll go through
this with examples we'll start with measuring the
influence of vo  n one or more
variables on another was
april could be of
interest as part of the research work what influences
children's ability to concentrate are
you interested in, i.e. whether it can be
proven that there
are parameters that have a positive or negative influence on children's ability to concentrate,
but you are not involved
interested in predicting children's ability
to concentrate or you could
investigate whether the level of education of the
parents and the place of residence has an influence
on the future level of education of
children these two areas are
very research-heavy and are used a lot
in social and
economic sciences
the second area is regression for
to use prediction it is
practical to get the most out of hospital
approval you might be
interested in how long a patient stays in the
hospital i.e. based on
the characteristics of the prospective patient
such as age the reason for the stay  stop
and if you have a pre-existing condition you would like to know
how long this person is likely to stay in the
hospital based on this
prediction the bed planning can then be
optimized or as the operator of
an online shop you are very
interested in which product a person is
most likely to buy this product
you want the visitor then  suggest to increase the
sales of the online shop
here a revision is
used now there are different types
of regression analysis these are
not difficult to understand so
we start right away
with the recession analysis we distinguish between
the simple linear the multiple
linear and the logistic  recession
differences in simple linear
regression you use only one
independent variable to infer the
dependent variable in the
example where we want to predict a person's
salary we use only
one variable either whether one has
studied or not the weeks  hours
worked or a person's age
multiple linear regression
uses several independent
variables so you use the
highest level of education the hours worked each
week and
a person's age
therefore the difference between a
simple linear regression and a multiple linear
regression is that in one case there is
only one  independent variable is
used and in the other case several
both have in common that the dependent
variable metric metric variables
are for example a
person's salary height or e.g. electricity
consumption which faces the
logistic recession the logistic
recession is used when you have a
categorical dependent variable  have eg
if you want to infer is whether
a person is at risk of burnout brother
not always if you answer yes no
are you using a logistic
recession a person buys a product
yes or no is a person healthy or
sick  does a person choose a certain
party yes or no and so on and
so forth in all of these cases it doesn't matter
what scale level independent
variables have these can be either
nominal original or metric
as said that even level the dependent
variable can in all three cases ie
in the simple linear in the
multiple linear and in the
logistic recession metrically original
or nominal the dependent
variable is metric in the linear case
and in the case of the logistic regression
nominal or original
it should be noted that with nominal or
original independent variables the
variables are classically only two
Characteristics port may such
as the gender male and
female had a variable more than
two characteristics then you have to
form so-called dummy
variables we will come to dummy variables later in
this video now a short
repetition there is the simple
linear regression a question can  e
its does the weekly working time have
an influence on the hourly wage
of employees what is special here is that
we only have one independent variable
there is multiple linear regression
do the weekly working time and
the age of employees have an
influence on the hourly wage here
we have two independent variables and
While hours worked per week and
age, therefore, we use multiple
linear regression and the last case is
the logistic recession,
hours worked per week and age of employees do affect the likelihood that they
are at risk of burnout or not, with burnout
endangering the yes/no salience
now you have got a good overview of
what the recession
analysis is actually used for and we can
look at the simple and multiple linear
regression in more detail
as you now know the
recession analysis can be used to determine
the influence of  one or more
independent
variables to measure a dependent value
in the case of simple linear regression
there is only one independent variable in the
case of multiple linear regression
there are at least two independent
variables both have in common that the
dependent variable is a metric
variable which is the goal of simple
Line recession Is it possible to predict the value of a
dependent variable based on an
independent variable The
greater the linear
relationship between the independent and dependent
variable, the more accurate the
prediction is. Visually, the
relationship between the variables can be represented in a scatter
plot, the greater
the linear relationship  between the
dependent and independent variable is
the more the data points lie
on a straight line the task of the
simple lines recession is it
precisely these that determine the
linear connection between the
dependent and the independent  important variable
is best described within the framework of the
simple the more detailed regression
analysis is expressed graphically, a straight line is drawn in the scatter diagram to
determine this
directly, the linear regression
uses the method of least squares
let’s say a hospital
commissioned and you should give the hospital
a  give an estimate based on the
age of a person how long this
person will stay in the hospital after an operation the hospital
operator would like to
optimize its planning your dependent variable i.e.
the one you want to conclude from is
the length of stay after an operation an
independent variable is the age the
equation the  your model describes
now looks like this he is the
slope and is the on point it does
not matter in this case we are but if
a person is 0 years old the
model would say that this person
stays in the hospital for days so you
can calculate the coefficients  nst the
hospital must of course give a
random sample of people whose
age and length of stay
after an op shows with which the
data you have available you could
find out, for example, that b is 0.14 and
1.2 that is now your model with  who can estimate the
length of stay after an operation based
on the age now
a person who is 33 years old is registered for
an operation then we set fix
33 1 our model then tells us that
this person stays in the hospital for two days after an operation 58
the question  is
now of course how do i calculate the
slope b and how do i calculate the at
point a usually
you simply use a statistics program
like data tab for this in the case of simple
internal revision is still
quite easy to do by hand b results
from the correlation  of the two
variables times the standard deviation of
the variable length of stay after
an operation by the standard deviation
of the altar erg  it is calculated by calculating the
mean value of the length of stay -
the slope times the
mean value of
the age the recessions are currently trying to map
the given data with
a straight line as best as possible of course there
is an error this
error is called epson let's say we
estimate the endurance of a  person
who is 33 years old our model says
the person stays 5.8 two days in the
hospital
this person actually stays
in the hospital for seven days then the
difference between the estimated value
and the value of the goods is our error
exactly the error y so you have it now
a good overview of what simple
linear regression is and we
now come to multiplayer
versus simple linear regression the in a
recession the
nearer region can
take into account two or more independent variables in multiples the
objective is therefore one
variable based on several others
to estimate variables like w  we already know the
variable that is to be estimated
is called the dependent variable
criterion the variables that are used for the
prediction are called
independent variables projectors with
the multiple line a recession
it is now possible to control so-called rip variables
the multiple line
recession often occurs in the
empirical social research as well as in
market research for use in both
areas it is of great interest to
find out what influence
different factors have on a variable
therefore the equation for a simple
recession looks like this we have
an independent variable plus the
constant let's go to the
multiples the internal revision we have
several independent variables first
variable the second variable and the
card variable the coefficients can
now be interpreted similar to the lines recession
are all
independent was inherited 0 the
value changes  if an independent
variable changes by one unit, the
associated coupe indicates how much the
dependent variable changes, so if
we
look at this equation below, for example, we have
25.39 times age, therefore if a
person is one year older, it deserves
it  according to the model
25.39 euros more before i show you how
to interpret the results of a line on
recession i will
first show you how you
can easily calculate the linear regression online and
we can then take the results
straight away for this you just go up
to date  up de you can find the link
in the video description copies
your own data in this table of
these data sets is of course
actually
your own data set can of course be
much, much larger
then click on recession now
the variable names appear down here that
you copy into the table  have we
can choose once a dependent variable
and an independent one  ge variable
let's say we take the income as the dependent
variable and
the gender,
age and weight of a person as the independent variable now
the results will be
given to you below right away why
interpret these results let's go
straight through what
datatec still has as additional information  Provides is
a word summary so
you can either browse through the
tables or just
click on word summary A
multiple linear regression was
performed to examine whether the
variables male age weight
significantly predict the variable income
that the recession model shows
that the protectors 35  explain 4 percent of the
variance and a significant
effect was not found
you can also always click on the lamps
here and then you will get an
explanation of the respective table
but first we will go
through the results slowly you will get
these three  i output stages let's start
with the model summary
in the table you get
the multiple correlation sco
efficient first it outputs this captures
the relationship or the correlation
between the dependent variable and the
independent variables what does that
mean right here we see the
recession equation with  using the
recession model we calculate an
estimate of the dependent variable
now of course we can calculate the correlation
between the estimated dependent
variable and the commodity dependent
variable this is now our
coalition grossert the greater this
correlation is the more accurate our
model is if there is no correlation at all
returns then we have not gained any information
from this recession
model next comes the variance
explanation r square this indicates how
much of the variance of the dependent variable
can be explained by the independent variables therefore our dependent
variable has me  a certain range of
fluctuation, for example the
length of stay of a person after
an operation varies from person to person
we want to explain as much of this range of fluctuation as possible
through the
independent variables such
as age or previous illnesses if
we can explain as much variance as
possible we have a large r square  in
that case we can explain 35 percent of the
variance then there is the
adjusted r square if there are many
independent variables then
the variance overestimates the explanation of the r
square to avoid this
the adjusted er square is used
and finally there is then  nor the
standard error the standard
rate reflects how much the model misjudges
the mean when predicting the dependent variables
let's take the
example of the hospital
stay there will be a standard estimation error of two
days it would mean
that we usually estimate by two  guess days
The hospital operator will probably say how long a person stays in the
hospital during
eight days, for example
, hey
, that’s a bit too precise
, unfortunately we can’t
do anything with this estimate, the model
usually misestimates by two days, the
hospital operator will probably
say  great we can do something with this
estimate let's now come
to the next table the statistical
validation here an eleventh is
calculated to check the zero hypothesis
whether the variance explains the
square in the population leaves 0 the
test is often not of great interest
this is  because the test is equally
important to the assertion that all
were slope coefficients
are 0 in the population, so if we look at
this recession equation,
the test checks whether all coefficients b1
b2 up to known in the
population are 0 in this case since
we have one  used a very small data
set  n we cannot even
refute the null hypothesis and
based on the data we assume
that all coefficients b1 to bka in
the population are 0,
but this is most likely due to the fact that it is
very difficult to achieve significant results with such a
small data set
now we come to the table that is
probably the most interesting for
you here we see the and
standardized coefficients the
standardized coefficients and the
significance level the and
standardized coefficients are the patients
that you can use in your recession equation so in
our case it would be  the salary is obtained
by taking the constant
1920 - the coefficient for is
male which is 372 plus the
coefficient for age which is
25.39 - the coefficient for
weight which is minus 5.1 56 at
this course you can ducks  now
read how much the salary changes
whom  n the corresponding independent
variable changes by one unit
accordingly we have a person
who is one year older today
estimate our model that this person
earns 25.39 euros more or a
person who weighs a kilogram more earns
six euros less higher minus 5.15
or if a person is male
, according to this model they will
at least be
372 euros less than a female
person with the standardized ones
but you cannot read which variables
actually have the greatest influence on the
healed this can be done with the
standardized coefficients
here you can see  that age
has the greatest value in terms of amount and
thus has the greatest influence on
salary finally we
also see the proven here the
zero hypothesis is always checked that the and
standardized coefficient in the population is
actually zero if
the ph value or significant  level is
less than 0.05 this can be 0
hypothesis will be rejected otherwise
it will be retained i.e. if you have values ​​here
on the right that are
less than 0 05 you can
assume that the respective variables have had
a significant influence on the
healed again the same topic
our data network is so small that it is
difficult  is to come to significant
results and we
have no
significant influence on the salary of
any of the patients all values ​​or significant are greater
than 0.05 but only values ​​less than 0.5
we had considered significant
what you are still missing are the
Requirements that your data must meet
so that you can calculate a regression analysis at all
let’s start with the
requirements for linear
regression analysis
a brief overview the requirements
for linear regression are there must be
a linear relationship between the
dependent and independent
variables very important actually  i is that
the main requirement the error y must be
normally distributed
there must be no multipolarity
or unstable
regression sco efficient there must be no
heterogeneity the variance of the
reside must be constant across the predicted
value ranges and
so we now go to each individual
point  exactly one at the end i
will show you how
you can check the requirements online it
starts with the linearity
in the line recession a
straight line is laid through the data this
straight line should map all points as well as possible if
the points are not linear
this can be this straight line  not fulfilling the task let's take a
look at these
two graphs in the first
graph we see a nice
linear connection between the dependent and
the independent variable
here the recession
can be put in in a meaningful way in the second case
, however, we see that there is a clear
non-linear relationship  There is a relationship between the
dependent and the independent
variable. It is therefore not possible to increase the
recessions in a meaningful way through these
points. Since this is not possible,
the costs of the
recession model cannot be meaningfully
interpreted in the end or there are
no errors in the forecast that
are larger  than expected
therefore it must be checked at the beginning whether
there is a linear connection between the
dependent and the respective
independent variables this is
usually checked graphically
the next requirement is that the
error apps long
must be normally distributed to check this there are two
ways once  the analytical way and
once the graphical way with the
analytical way either the
kolmakov smirnov test or the schapiro
bild test can be used if the way is
greater than 0.05 there is no deviation of
the data from the normal distribution so
it can be assumed that the data
are normally distributed each  The
analytical
tests are also used less and less because they always tend
to attest normal distribution with small samples and to become
significant more quickly with large samples and
reject 0 hypotheses
because the data are normally distributed,
so the graphic variants are used more and more
for the graphic
variant  do you use either the
histogram or better the so-called
sphere the more the data on this
line ling the better the
normal distribution is
you want more detailed information on how
you can now check the normal distribution
just watch
my video so we can come
back now that zed  a prerequisite
for linear regression is that the
isi have a constant variance because
in practice the recession model never
exactly predicts your dependent variable
you always have an error now you can
plot your dependent variable on the x-
axis and the error on the  yac
hse now the error should spread evenly over the entire
area then there is
homosexuality if the result looks like this
then there is
heterogeneity in this case there are
different error variants depending
on which value range we are in
from the dependent variable that
must not be and now  we
come to the final requirement of
multicar linearity
multipolarity means that two or
more independent variables
correlate strongly with each other
the problem with multipolarity is that
the effect of individual
variables cannot be clearly separated
let's look again at the
recession equations we have
the dependent one here  variable and here the
independent variable with the respective
coefficients, for example, there is a
high correlation between x1 and
x3 or if these variables are almost the
same then it is difficult
to determine b1 and b2 are both completely the
same, for example knows that recession m  odell not
ko s b 1 and how big should be two
the reaction model is then unstable
if you want to use the recession model for
a forecast it
doesn’t matter with a forecast you are only interested in
how good the forecast is
but not how big the
influence of the  respective variables is
accordingly it does not matter if the
individual costs have not been determined correctly,
however, the government model is
used to measure the influence of the
independent variable
on the dependent variable
must not be multipolar because
if it is present the coefficients
cannot be meaningfully interpreted how
can one  now
diagnose multipolarity let's look at
the repression equation again then here
we have the variable x1 x2 up to
xk we now want to know whether x1 is quite
identical to any of the other
variables or a
combination of the other variables for
this we simply assume
new recession model included in these
regions model we take x1 as a new
dependent variable
if we can
now very well infer x1 with the other independent variable
, it means that we can make the same
statement that we can make with x1
with a combination of the
other variables
therefore x1 is more or less superfluous
and under certain circumstances makes the
government model stable if, for
example, you can put x1 together completely from the other
variables then
the government model cannot know
what b1 is or what the
other patients should be in
mathematics they say  then the
line system is determined via
this we can now also do for all other
variables so we estimate x2
depending on other variables and
we estimate xk depending on the
other variables for all new
recession models in this case
we have new recession models
we calculate  the so-called to  tolerance and the value
the tolerance results from 1 - the
specific measure or the variance explanation again as a
reminder the
variance explanation indicates how much of the
variance of x1
can be explained by the other variables the
more that is the more likely one
speaks of  multipolarity because we
actually want each individual
variable to have as little as possible to do with the others
the tolerance and the
0.1 should be careful and there
may be multipolarity
on the other hand we still have
the value the value is calculated by 1
due to the tolerance dubai has to be
careful with values ​​greater than ten
so and now i’ll show you how you
can check the requirements online
let’s say you take the income again as a dependent
variable and
age and weight as independent variables
then simply click on
check requirements  now you get
a requirement checked once
k  then you check for linearity so
here it is again how it should look like
and how it shouldn't look like
and you can see here if
income has a linear relationship with age and
income with ever weight and you can also
see if the  error component is
normally distributed this is the
analytical test there is a
value greater than 0 5 everywhere so it can
be assumed that the data is normally
distributed but here you have exactly
the point that it is only a very
small data set and therefore
Normal distribution is very quickly attested,
although there may not be any,
but if we
look at the graphical variant, according to the coup,
one could just about
speak of normal distribution here, the data are
on a line, but here we have
a few outliers, furthermore,
multiculturalism is checked  with the
tolerance and value and the
heterogeneity
now that we have the vora  Having
discussed the suspensions, let's now go to the
tami variables, or if
you have categorical variables and they
are a recession model on which you want to go, you
can use either metric
or categorical variables with two characteristics as independent variables or
projectors. You can find out how this can be expanded  in the
next spring categorical variables
with two values ​​will also be referred to as the
atom an example would be
gender with the values ​​male
and female let's say female is
cured with zero and male is coded with 1
in which case female would then be
the reference category if
now let's take a look at the
government model and say the
variable x1 is gender the b1 of
the regression skoff cents for
gender now how can we
interpret b1 we said 0 is
female and one is male
so let's just put that in then
have  we at a female  person 0
x b 1 and for a male person
once b1 accordingly gb 1 the
difference between male and
female let's say we want to
predict the income of a person so
y is the income if this person is
male they earn b1 more
or less if the sign is negative
salary as if this person were
a woman if b1 is 372, for example
, then that would mean that a
male person earns 372 euros more
than a female person because
in the upper case we would calculate 372 1 0
and in the lower case 3 172 x 1 so
always  if we have a male person
, all other things being equal, we will then find out
once healed
what is 372 euros higher
so we have now discussed how
we deal with variables with two characteristics
and now we can
look at what we do with variables that
have more than two  characteristics
let's say you want to assume the consumption of
a car  end of its hp number
and the vehicle type and
let's say there are only three vehicle
types sedans sports cars and
families we have here a variable
vehicle type with more than two
characteristics in the recession we
can only consider categorical variables with two
characteristics there  now the
question is what do we do now so that we can use
categorical variables with more than two characteristics
we have to form
so-called da with variables that
means that we simply
make three new variables from our variable with three characteristics,
each with two
characteristics so we have here  choose our
vehicle type with the characteristics
sedan sports bench and families
now we make a new variable from each individual characteristic
we
set the variable once is it a
sedan yes or no is it a
sports car yes or no and is it a
family yes or no
before we had a variable now we have
three variables that are only the
atoms and therefore only have two
characteristics and we can use these
reduced ones for the
region how would that look now for
your collected data you
originally have a column with vehicle
tip where the individual vehicles from
a random sample are listed  the
first is a sedan
the second is also a sedan the
third is a sports car and so on
and so forth from this now measure your three
new variables what is the first car
a sedan so put a 1 here
and a zero for the other two
put it  is not a sports car and also
not a family who the second is again
a sedan so comes a 1 here
the third is a sports car comes along
1 1 theirs and the others 0
so we have now formed our lady
variables now there is one more thing
to note  are always the number
of characteristics - a star formed with
variables why is it like that when we
know  If it's a sedan
we're sure it's not a family
if if we know it's a
sports car we're also
sure it's not family fun but it's
not a sedan and it's not a
sports car we're sure it's
a  family if is so one of the
three variables is good and we can cross it
out like for example
is family went back we
still have the same information
because if it is a small sedan and
not a sports car we know that a
family if is the same  you could
also omit one of the other variables
and now i'll show you
again the lady variables
you can easily create with the app let's say
you want to have the income
dependent on the company
so let's look at income
and at company the
company  in this case has three
forms bmw daimler and vw so
you have to form the variables here but
the s  nice is that the data tab does it
automatically for you if we
scroll down here now we see the
constant we are once the therme
variable is the bmw and is that
daimler and the last variable there as
always one lady variable less than the
number of  expression is
omitted vw because it is very
simple you just need to select the variables
with which you
want to calculate a regression and data tab
you automatically create the lady variables if
i your independent variable is
categorical but a dependent
so your criterion then you have to have one
calculate logistic regression and what
a logistic region is let's
look now in
the previous section we
looked at linear regression
here the dependent variable had metric
sculli before so for example salary
or height but if you have a
categorical variable you have to have a
logistic recession
say use  you want to predict whether a
person is at risk of
getting a berner yes or no depending
on the highest level of education the
weekly working hours and the age of
the person since the variable of whether a
person is at risk of burnout or not is
a categorical variable a
logistic recession is used
the  logistic recession is a
special case of regression analysis and
is calculated on the dependent variable
nominally scaled or
originally escalated let's
just look at three examples
start with an example from the
economy for an online retailer
you should say in advance which product
a customer is most likely to buy  buys for this
receives a data set with
past visitors and their purchases
from the online shop the variable which
product a customer bought is
categorical therefore used a logistical
recession or an example
from medicine you want to investigate
whether a pers  on is susceptible to a certain
disease or not for
this you will receive a data set with
sick and non-sick people
as well as other medical parameters
a logistic region is
used again had a categorical
dependent variable is a person
susceptible yes or no to a certain
disease and that  the last example
from politics would a person
vote for a party if the next weekend
behave again as an answer yes or
no
so again what is now a
logistic recession in the basic form of
the logistic recession atoms variables can be
predicted so 0 became 1
for this the
probability for  the occurrence of the
expression 1 i.e. characteristic present
estimated in medicine, for
example, a common goal is to
find out which variables have an
influence on a disease in
this case 0 can stand for not
ill and one for ill
and it is examined which one
age, gender and smoking
status have an influence on this particular
disease if we take a quick
look at this below so our independent
variables are age, gender
and smoking status and with the help of
these independent variables we want
to conclude whether a certain
disease is present or not
to solve this problem a logistic
region is used now you are
probably asking yourself why not
just a normal linear
regression in a line recession is
that our recession equation
but we now have a dependent variable
which is either 0  or 1 because no matter
what value the dependent variables
assume, the independent variable is
always zero or one if we were to use a
linear regression,
we would simply insert a straight line into
these points, but we can
see here in the graphic that in this
case values ​​are between  minus and plus
infinity  Although we
actually only want values ​​between 0 and
1, the aim of the logistic
recession is
to estimate
the probability of occurrence and not the value of the variable itself. The range of values ​​for this prediction
is restricted to the value between 0
and 1  values
between 0 and 1 are possible, the
so-called logistic function f is
used
the logistic model is based on the
logistic function what is special about
the logistic function is that for
values ​​between minus and plus infinity
it only ever assumes values ​​between 0 and 1
and that is exactly what it is  what we want the
equation for the logistic recession
now looks like this 1 multiplied by one plus -
z leads we can now use the usual
equation from the line
region so we have b1 malik
science + b 262 and so on and so
on now the task is
to determine the coefficients b1 to bka and so
that the data as good as possible
the  probability of occurrence of the
dependent variable reflecting
this is done using the maximum nike
hat method there is a good
numerical solution for this and now i will tell you
how you can calculate the logistic recession using the
web for
this you copy your own
data back into the table from datatec
say  we you want to predict in
dependency and the salary and age
of a person whether that person will
buy a certain product or not so
you have a categorical dependent
variable with yes and no as an answer now
you just click on recession again
and choose buys as the dependent variable
product from as an independent variable
you want the salary and the old from since
the dependent variable is a categorical
variable, the update
automatically calculates a logistic recession
you can see here in the upper table how
many cases were correctly assigned
and what percentage that is you can see
here  below the classification  gs table
and further here and you see the model
summary you get the kof e.g.
the standard error the time value the ph
value and the local defense shot again this
is only a very small data set
accordingly it is difficult
to interpret these results meaningfully
I hope the video has  you like it and
see you next time bye